Shriya I know you had quite an intensive
workshop with director Deva mess before
you actually started filming Midnight's
Children tell me about that workshop was
very intense by the end of it I thought
I'm gonna die but I didn't and at a time
that I thought deep I hated me but then
she loved me and I loved her I love her
for loving me I think what what workshop
related to me is that it deeper helped
me go beyond my borders explore my
explore my myself find myself and
understand things about myself I didn't
know it just she just gave me wings and
she she took me to a cliff and she said
up top now and I had to just jump and
trust her and trust myself for me that
was a learning experience yes um it's a
magical magical character it's a magical
magical scenes for me every scene is
really important because I've done that
from my heart from all my honesty and I
hope people like it and love it I'm
doing the handheld stuff as well to that
help with the intimacy because she was
filming handheld wasn't she well yeah
Giles did it really well it was the
whole idea was the actors just do what
they have to do and camera sort of sort
of travels around them it was almost the
camera was as invisible Laura's not
there is like wind or like air is just
we didn't even know it existed and I
sort of really helped actually yeah it
did yeah and tell us about that kiss as
well the case in the film is I don't
know where to see
you